dude capitalism is so important think
about this
you got these socialist
a-holes in the world who want
i'm going to tell you where stick with
me here for a second all right
you saw the opportunity and suffered for
a decade through it
because we have a capitalistic society
where a person who's willing to suffer
and take risks like yourself
credit card debt you know 401k
you do that because there is a reward in
part
for doing that sure and there are people
who don't understand that capitalism as
flawed as it can be on the margins
it's the best system because the
ramification of
your success you and your partners not
giving up a very
individual sacrifice that's what
capitalism is about at its core
individuals believing they can change
the world now the ripple effect
of what you're doing the 10 000 startups
that will exist every year
and then next year 100 000 and maybe a
million that i'll invest in nyc will
invest in
in metro capitals that catalytic effect
is what makes the human species go
forward
and creates wealth for everybody the
trickle-down effect and people like
trickle-down doesn't exist
the fact that you're going to enable a
group of people who are not developers
to make websites and businesses and then
i
i or yc is going to look at that and say
yeah no code's a thing no we're not
going to be
precious about it being no code yeah
you're going to enable
another whole swath of people to
participate
in capitalism do you realize how
profound that is i think that's
super profound i wouldn't attribute that
to capitalism
though like what drives me personally is
the impact and the dent in the universe
not like you know money or how much
stock i own but go ahead and try it in
russia or china
totally i think i think that's a because
if you do it in russia or china
they're going to basically take the
business from you absolutely yeah i mean
i'm
i'm a dual russian citizen i'm not a
citizen here and there i would not go
start a business there so i think the
system here that incentivizes
entrepreneurship is amazing i think the
uh sort of systemic effects of how
much uh you know founders are like
whether it's through attention or money
or like um it's weird like how much
they're incentivized
right to sometimes you have like this
500 to one ratio between
a ceo and and a person doing like
incredibly hard work to get that mission
to happen that that feels systemically
uh it just incongruous right here's the
great thing
you can do what you want in your company
if you feel that pressure you can do it
and if bill gates wants to not do that
yeah and then give all those money at
the end you can do that too
yep that's good that's what the i you
know it's interesting i like the fact
that
you're not buying into my total picture
of this and i think it's a good punch up
yeah i have like a little bit of a um
there's so many
so many uh points of privilege that i
was
i was i benefited from sure uh that
i wouldn't say it was all my effort so
like for example i'm
personally fine with paying more in
taxes because i've seen
how much that like that infrastructure
like sergey and i my brother and i uh
the first two months we worked from a
library for free
yeah uh in order to get waffle off the
ground we couldn't afford like a
co-working space
yeah uh and that is there because like
um you guys born in russia we were born
in russia yeah
so you have a different an even
different level of appreciation right we
came here
in america right yeah as refugees when i
was nine um
so the other crazy thing about this
goddamn president
who wants to stop people like you from
coming into this country this is why
we have to stop this maniac from
deploying
an immigration policy that will
stunt our ability to have people like
you come here
it's short-sighted it's xenophobic it's
it's
literally the i mean the what's the goal
there
to to rile up um
kind of more white supremacism
supremacists to support
him like it's a cheap shot it's it's so
cheap and then let's unpack it for a
second
we allow you russians from a communist
authoritarian country to come here you
appreciate that opportunity so much
absolutely that you are willing to work
for a year to build this company
you create massive wealth for a large
team of people
that enables the next generation of
builders if you weren't allowing this
country you had to stay in russia what
would you be doing
okay working for the state so even worse
uh
this is i just have to share the story
because uh
my direct cousin so my my mom's sister's
uh son who was you know same age as me
we grew up together
uh just down the street they ended up
moving into our house once we left
russia
um i visited russia in 2007 with my wife
and i had a conversation with him around
like what he's doing for a living
he gets up at so his job is to work for
a government agency
um that gets paid by i don't remember if
it's a world bank or the imf some sort
of
international organization that that
incentivizes
countries especially bric countries to
reduce
carbon emissions so his job is to go
like
find leaks in pipelines gas pipelines
and close them
and then document that and
make sure that it's listed in like some
monthly ledger and then
and then the government the local
government gets paid for that
that's his job from ten to five uh from
six
to nine thirty his job is to go and open
leaks in pipes so that he can discover
them
later in the day lord so like
and complete hit on his like morality he
he hates doing this right this is the
only thing you can do to put
food on the table he like his his like
the boss that is working at the kind of
crony local government yeah
like this makes me feel terrible just
talking about this um
he has no other he has complete control
over it over my cousin
uh and and he's like just heartbroken
that he has to do this work
and and that that i'd probably be doing
something like that yeah that's the
problem
see socialism looks like a great great
on paper everybody shares equally yadda
yadda
and then you put people in charge and
the human nature is
it turns into terrorists and you know
that because you lived it
you got a generation here who thinks
that that's pretty good to me
yeah let everybody get the same thing
let's have no incentive structure and
then we have no incentive structure you
know what people do
they create it they create it in the
underground they start paying people off
and corruption
and you know power corrupts yeah it's i
mean it's uh
not to get too political here but i
think it's a too late it's a spectrum
it's a spectrum right of course yes a
safety net the reason it actually took
me two years longer
to start webflow because i was worried
about health insurance yeah
i would have started it earlier had was
there a
um a safety net where i didn't have to
worry about my kids being sick it is
socialism is completely a spectrum
we give k through 12 in this country for
free absolutely if we gave k
pre-k through 14 which would be like
or nursery school plus two years of
trade school
it's no difference it wouldn't be any
sweat off our backs here to do a little
bit and
but if you present it as free college
and the interpretation is yeah
go two hundred thousand dollars in debt
to some crazy school
as opposed to a trade school for two
years you know then that's not a line
yeah
and you have things like um things that
are just like straight
up bad for business uh but they feel
like they're being
um you know anti-socialist so for
example uh the united states is one of
the only actually i think the only
developed country that has zero mandated
um
like parental leave weeks that you that
you
can't leave a job without risking losing
it yeah it's crazy
it's it's just nuts like it it's bad for
the businesses where those people work
for them to be
you know freaked out or not being able
to land so so there's like a a
huge gradient where we can't let you
know kind of
i don't know like the the great thing
about the discussion we're having here
is you and i maybe don't agree on
everything sure
but we can have a rational discussion
about it and the problem when you put
a despot into a democracy like we have
a narcissist despotic person is they
shut the discussion down
by letting the extremes take it over
there's the same thing going on in
russia which was putin's playbook yeah i
mean his entire playbook is to cause
chaos around the world so he doesn't
look so bad right
right and to make people feel like well
you know what look at america like
they're killing each other based on the
color of their skin like
maybe the bread line's not so bad